on his clock because just the momentum
change he knew he was completely winning
three or four moves ago
suddenly white is uh why is the one
creating all the threats
creating all the confusion and why do
you even go with that black rook it's
not looking simple
at all you might have to lose time with
your bishop to defend it i was going to
say i would move my bishop
one square back but then again why did i
put it on that square
okay 14 seconds for wesley so here yeah
he has to make a decision fine he has to
do it quickly
i suspect oh no but this is a
is this even possible can you not just
bishop take that bishop look at magnus
frowning
he knew he knows that he's winning now
he's shocked by wesley's last move and
stockfish confirms it the computer shows
queen takes bishop wins magnus wins the
game wesley resigns immediately
wesley saw just gives up magnus carlsen
this was a dramatic game he ends up
winning this game and look at him he
looks shocked
yeah i think he's shocked about his own
blunder earlier but also shocked that
he's smiling he's also shocked that
wesley's